from the white house a warning to the
world
we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital key
a city of 2.8 million innocent people
the u.s says their intelligence
indicates that russian president
vladimir putin is already on the path to
invasion
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
president biden stressed the daughter
diplomacy is still open but seemingly
only just
a huge moment in this ongoing and
unpredictable crisis the biden
administration had been saying an attack
was highly likely they then said an
attack was imminent president biden now
saying he believes that president putin
has made his mind up to invade
russia now poses such a threat from the
sea and on the ground they could stage
an attack at any time it might also come
from the air
these satellite images showing a new
deployment of more than 20 helicopters
on russia's border with ukraine
today the u.s vice president kamala
harris will address a conference in
munich about world security the stakes
couldn't be higher martha kellner sky
news washington